Francis sign with the pfl shout out to
Francis ingano he said what he was going
to do he set out what he's going to do
he got a lot of hate a lot of pushback
his agent Markel and him got it done all
of it's all good biggest contract
guarantees his opponents of two million
dollars he hits a portion of the gate
pay-per-view percentage guaranteed money
question is is it a great deal for the
pfl history would say no the leagues
that throw all this money at the
fighters Affliction other leagues
they're not around anymore so I don't
know if you can sustain a business model
given Francis all this money all this
power I don't know if it's cable I hope
it is other question who's he gonna
fight
name five pfl heavyweights go so they're
gonna have to make pfl an attractive
kind of secondary option uh outside the
UFC which they've done because now
you're guaranteeing them these huge
payday so I think you're going to see
some free agents come over to the pfl